みんなはー
ポテトチップス好きかい？
そう、世の中には様々なポテトチップスが存在する
それはもう星の数ほどあるさ
中にはわけもわからない味もある、だろ？
そう、実は今ポテトチップスというものは
味の種類が沢山ありすぎて
何を食べればいいかわからなくなっちゃう時がある
そうだろ？
そこで俺は考えた
そう！コンビニにあるすべてのポテトチップスを買ってきて
そのポテトチップスを
そう！そうすることによって
ポテトチップスそれぞれが味があるんだよ
色んな味がありすぎてどれ食べていいかわかんない
だから！俺は全てのポテトチップスを一つの味に凝縮する
色んなポテトチップスの会社は考えてるわけですよ
どうすれば美味しいポテトチップスができるのか
考えて考えて色んな味を考えて作る作る作る
そうすることによって
大量のポテトチップスの味の種類ができた
だが今そのポテトチップスを一つの味にする時が来た
多分、主要な物は全部あります
全ての到達点だと僕は思ったわけですよ
皆の気持ちが一つになった時
最高のポテトチップスが
生まれるのさ。
ではいこう！
混ぜていきま　しょう！
しょう！
きゃあああ
カルビーうすしお味
うん！美味しい！
のりしお
美味しい
関西風すきやき味
俺は思った
とても面倒くさい！
なので最後にまとめて潰します
はい、ライムソルト
うん、美味い
スコーン　バーベキュー
スタミナガーリック
うめー
カルビーフライ　さやえんどう
炙りユッケ
すだちおろし！
うめーわこれ
復刻版カラムーチョ
あーﾝ！
あ、辛い
極旨のり塩！
あーう！
東京下町もんじゃ焼き
あーう！これうめー
カラムーチョ！
あーう！
関西風すきやき
あーう！うめー
CoCo壱チーズカレー味
チーズカレーの味がする
あー！
あーう！あー！あー！
アッアッアッアッアッアッうまい！
うまい！アラァッ！
アッアッアッアッアッ
あーーｳ！
ｱｳｱｳｱｳｱｳｱｳｱｰｵ!
あーお！あーお！あーお！あーーお！
あーお！
あーーーーーう！！
ちょっと落ち着こう
普通にやろう、落ち着け落ち着け
ちょっと落ち着いてやろうぜ落ち着いて
あーお！
あー！あーお！
あーー！
蟻が来るからまじこういうのはやだわ
というわけで無事なんとかすべてのポテトチップスを
1つの容器にまとめれたので
これを1つの粉にします
*粉砕中*
よーーし
お母さんごめんなさい！
はいというわけで何はともあれ完成しました
こちらが今あるポテトチップスを
全種類合わせた魔法の粉でございます
ハンマーでちょっと飛び散っちゃったんですけども
はたしてどんな味なのかっていうところが見どころですね
いただきます！
あ？
美味い！美味いのはわかる
これは
かっぱえびせんだ